but all of that is gone all of it's gone  all of it and it's gone because of all  the ideas we were discussing earlier the  feminism the new age [ __ ] the  [ __ ] dudes left and right and Center  all these things all these Baseline  things have eroded Society to the point  where now you have men ignoring their  paternal Instinct you have men who will  sit there and go that's my child but  [ __ ] her  that that is that that's actually a  massive observation to make about how  [ __ ] up Society is and it's all and it  shouldn't be that way because men in a  lot of the world are not like that  because so you have to look at all these  small things the small things we talk  about it's no big deal she goes on boats  in Miami it's no big deal it is a big  deal because now that dude ain't gonna  want to [ __ ] pay child support  because you were on those [ __ ] boats  with this [ __ ] the other team